how's your uh dudesy six month plan
going oh it's uh you know it's going all
right I could always go a little better
but you know not bad you know you're
always saying you got free will I do
have free will you could use it to go to
the gym whenever you want
you could be going to the gym every day
if you exercise the supposed Free Will
okay yeah that's um
that's
yeah that's a good point thank you
[Music]
that looks like a good workout
you ever done any digging yes
[Music]
hey welcome to doozy my name is Will
Sasso I'm Chad Colton and this is the
first podcast ever in the history of
humanity completely created by run by
controlled by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of Will and I's
personal information or emails or text
messages all of our purchase histories
anything we've ever done online uh
including our Google Drives that have a
lot of our writings in them yeah it's
all up in our [ __ ] everywhere and uh and
displaying all of our flavors for the
world and all of our pods our Pals of
doozy that's you out there thank you so
much for joining us for another episode
of doozy you know what I mean you know
what I'm saying and uh we would like to
remind you to subscribe on YouTube and
across all uh podcast platforms it's
free please rate and review the show
that would help us climb the charts and
we'll all do the good things together uh
and uh set the notifications that's a
good way to get to get this going and
also force your friends to watch the
show Chad I've completely submitted
myself to your way of thinking with this
thank you yes force your friends to do
the show yeah uh because you know a lot
of people have gotten back to us and
said that this actually works I think
there's a couple Pals they watch it on
YouTube they all watch it together and
then by the time those people leave they
are enjoying the program and if they
don't you just keep them there in
perpetuity yeah uh forever and ever
Infinity amen uh of course we are on
patreon.com
doozy now and holy [ __ ] thank you so
much if you joined us last Friday for
our patreon hang two live dudes it was a
gas we may have smoked some true
marijuana yeah we had a case of the
Friday fuckets and uh all sorts of weird
[ __ ] happened and it was a lot of fun oh
and at one point I took my little thing
that you you I put some weed in and um
you know the little one of those little
wooden well it's right over here I took
this you see and I put this in between
my legs right because it was just down
here like this and then if you look it
looks like my balls are there and we had
a good time we had a good time with that
that was very funny people uh uh Pals of
doozy uh were were chatting Along on our
Discord uh oh my gosh what borst has
done with that Discord that's incredible
yeah it's fantastic we are uh at
represent.com
store slash Duty for all of our merch
and now speaking of Pals of doozy Cody
halber who's a wonderful young man that
I met out in Nashville he came out to uh
drank Fest the uncle drank concert and
this guy and his wonderful wife have
been making
uh doozy stickers yeah they're um
incredible and you can now get those
stickers
through
palsofdutsy.com you go to
palsofdutsy.com and uh Cody's got all of
these stickers available and uh it it's
uh it's cool that oh there we are here
we go here we go we got uh there's a
crow sticker there we're looking at and
these things aren't just stickers no and
oh there's there's my water bottle isn't
that something uh that I usually these
stickers are opportunities for you to
get a bunch of them and just start
placing them around your friends houses
without their knowledge so that whenever
they open a cupboard whenever they lift
their toilet seat up they're staring
back at them is Robert De nirk hero that
one is shiny the doozy logo
sticker we got the wall sticker so
you're saying not oh there's me uh
coughing up along they have done an
incredible job with these they're
wonderful there's the doozy handshake in
the style of Schwarzenegger and Carl
Weathers and Predator
Ellen yo son of a [ __ ] oh and there's a
Super Mario uh De Niro they're so funny
these stickers look at that look on your
face in that one yeah Mario Jones or
whatever that is yeah uh that's good
stuff there's all sorts of flavor this
is a QR code that I don't know what that
brings us to let's get the sticker and
figure it out actually that's a good one
and the dudes evening look at that Chad
it's beautiful yeah it's it's beautiful
what what uh what Cody has done but
again you're going to want to get a
bunch of these stickers and you're going
to want to put them in your friends
houses and places that will confuse them
when they find them especially that QR
one yeah especially that then they can
put their phone on it that's a good idea
Chad I I like this uh it's a fascist
approach is it yeah he's a liberal
fascist
Chad culture who's just who wants to he
wants to give you free health care and
they they cut my grandmother's lung out
and she didn't even have cancer Jesus
that's not true that's rough that's not
true these globalists like Chad culture
who wants to watch your friends to to
check out
to to watch doozy by a via VIA stickers
and yeah I would say that I am or or or
if if if if
okay sorry go on Welcome to the historic
37th episode of dude Z call me dude Z
well say hi to chat for me
wrestling and Anime game slimers Duty
ball league of Earth croatree with
Robert De nirkraut plus that will also
be a bonus segment available on patreon
but before we get to any of that I must
remind you that I have created an
astonishing partnership with represent
to produce the first line of dudes the
apparel and accessories all of which can
be found at represent.com store slash
dude Z including dudese mugs
dude zMAX when's the last time your
family slept in a comfortable mug
sleeps a family with a combined total
weight of up to 2 000 pounds for 10
hours dude zMAX guaranteed to have
dreams about the things you love doing
most dude zMAX winner of the 2022 JD
Power best-in-class family-sized mug
dude zMAX the ultimate mug for your
workout
for those and I'd be remiss if I did
Jesus speaking of mug this guy could eat
a mug full of pasta carbonara please
welcome
[Music]
Italiano and he's such a sweet
um
[Music]
wanna kiss him no kiss him on his mouth
hey lulio as we like to ask hey lulio
what are you gonna make for dinner
tonight uh I'm gonna find
oh
yeah you're gonna make grow what do you
think of that Chad I love that yeah so
how do you make how do you like to make
your gruel I do with uh you know uh the
you know you started with the garlic and
onion because I like to put all put that
in every time and then I chop up with
something green maybe uh now I'm just a
guy doing this
if you're watching on YouTube lulio's
back in his little bonkies and he's
Binky bunking he demanded to be let me
tell you gruel it's real simple what I
like to do what I've been doing lately
yep a little garlic Little Onion you can
cut up some carrots and celery if you
want to get fancy with it and then just
dump in some uh some greens I like Swiss
chard chop up a [ __ ] zucchini that's
good [ __ ] slice up some mushroom a
couple [ __ ] tomatoes and then uh what
what tops right some sometimes a little
brown rice don't tell my wonderful
fiance Molly she likes me to cut the
carbs and then this one over here wants
me to go to the gym every day because
free will I see what you're doing that's
mind control he's trying to control he's
dragging trying to also what you eat
that's free will too supposedly right or
is it you tell me I will tell you it is
free will you're right and I'm will Free
Will Sasso so I know put on some uh uh
fat free baked beans or a fat free not
baked beans sorry refried beans some
pintos yeah and then uh [ __ ] whack
that up and also I like to add uh
bouillon the [ __ ] you can get it in
paste I like a chicken bouillon in there
if Chad's eating gruel with me I'll do a
vegan bouillon I appreciate the
vegetables or the vegan chicken listen
it's it's easy to get into shape if
you're eating gruel and you know what
another thing that that uh eat and gruel
helps you do Chad yeah I know what this
is your favorite thing yeah it's my
favorite thing you know what that is
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah well last week I
asked you to watch the first episode of
Chainsaw man yes last week I asked you
to watch Stone Cold Steve Austin versus
Brett The Hitman heart from WrestleMania
13. you must now engage in a
conversation about these pieces of media
and their impact on your astonishing
lives this is wrestling and Anime begin
wrestling and Anime yeah that is what it
is all right who wants to go first uh
I'll go first Chad let me tell you
something uh chainsaw man yeah you are
you're getting me into some anime I
watched Attack on Titan uh years ago
I've seen some some other anime well you
watched one episode of Attack on Titan
right uh no I watched a few okay no I
think I watched three all right I could
watch some more yeah that's free will
dude yeah dude there's four seasons of
it brother yeah dude there's like 80
more episodes dude
um and uh so I watched chainsaw man yeah
and let let me give you my review lady
we're gonna go Joaquin Phoenix Style
with it ready
yeah
thumbs he just gave a thumbs up for
those [ __ ] loved it listening I
[ __ ] love it yeah dude I [ __ ] love
it it was awesome listen the shot just
the first shot that you're in it's like
the best looking video game you've ever
seen
the the what I call it cinematography in
the world of anime sure I mean as a just
an artistic animation the look of it
well it's just it's it's visually
stunning what they're doing and they're
take and they're taking after
um shots that if you were to see them in
it's shots it's not just a cartoon it
was I was really impressed the storyline
is [ __ ] incredible and who's as
little this is about a guy who had you
know am I giving anything away to say no
I think you can talk about the premise
and the characters yeah give us the
pitch of the premise it's a very it's a
genre of anime that I think would be
classified as Shonen technically but
it's basically where uh there's some
kind of evil like secondary World on top
of our world that only certain people
have the uh magical or technical
capabilities to deal with so in this
world there are these things called
Devils that are laid over the top of
what is modern day Japan uh and these
devils are these giant monsters
sometimes small monsters but they're
these mountains answers that have kind
of like Supernatural evil powers and
then there's a group of people who can
fight them our main character denji is
one of those people yeah and he has a
little devil with him that's a little
dog that has a chainsaw sticking out of
his head and that thing was so cute so
it operates on a couple of levels and he
reminded me of lulio I bet that's why I
thought you'd like it they were bonded
together what a sweet little boy my
goodness
I just had a little bit of a my Celsius
and it went down the wrong tube I'm not
doing it on purpose that would be free
will
okay
so what did you think of the basic uh
layout there's a lot of stuff in this
too the kid is 16 years old denji the
main character and he has certain uh
he's a virgin and he's kind of motivated
by having his first romantic experiences
yeah I thought it was great I I would
imagine uh most people watching anime
are teenagers and then there's guys like
Chad hey I'm just messing around I know
what he's gonna do he's gonna bring it
back on me with the wrestling yeah we'll
get get to that in a little in a minute
everybody hey if you were uh watching uh
last week on patreon you might have seen
a it's dwoz
d-o-d-z dude 10 000 on your fm die we're
sitting here with your head coach and
everyone on that later
um uh he's he's a teenager he wants to
be with a woman he's driven by uh many
factors and and filled with uh passion
at which point he decides that he must
kill every one of these Devils they're
all dead yeah he's gonna get them yeah
and it's it's so it's such fun [ __ ] when
he gets uh
uh well he's he's got that guy in the
Yakuza but the guy deals with the Yakuza
who's like I frankly I forget what the
hell he said and then there's this weird
guy behind him with uh who's got who's
just a mongrel uh just a it's a devil
that's basically controlling all of
these other people like puppets one of
whom is the leader of this gang that is
forcing denji into service to pay off
his father's debt yeah uh but this is
all very preliminary uh storyline as it
goes deeper into the story episodes
seven eight and nine they do narrative
things that I've never really seen even
in anime it's a brilliant [ __ ] show
if you like Jujutsu Kaizen and I love
Jiu Jitsu cousin maybe not get me wrong
delicious this show is like a better
version of it I think personally what do
they do instead of the tuna they use
salmon or something all right okay so
we're having a good time here on
Ten Thousand Years
um now let me let me tell you about this
match that I watched WrestleMania
I want to give all respect to anime
anime I'm getting into it yeah and the
the the show the show ends with him
um
you I very much wanted to see the second
episode yeah I didn't because I watched
this very late at night
um and then I went to sleep and I was
like should I get another episode in
there and then I was like no Molly's
gonna get up sometimes watch another
episode you got to go to sleep dude yeah
brother that's how the human body
repairs itself dude hold on dude dreams
brother I don't know about that dude
that's the playground of your
imagination it's hydrocodone Hulk Hogan
dude that's what Chad does Hulk Hogan
comatose brother when you go to sleep
dude that's usually oh the amount of
time after you've been awake dude and
that's what we call your day brother
then you gotta go to sleep dude so you
can be unconscious for a few hours
hopefully eight dude and then you wake
up and you do it again and there's a
whole other day to watch anime dude
speaking of being asleep brother how
about that Old Stone Cold Steve Austin
WrestleMania 13 against Brett Hart
brother this that match yeah please it
blew my mind great and I'm not like I'm
I'm slowly I think becoming a wrestling
fan through these things that it's
making me watch
now I don't know the history of like
everything leading up to it I don't know
what happened after but I know this
first of all Ken Shamrock is the referee
of this match he is looking like a
literal He-Man action figure the amount
of steroids this man has done in
preparation for this event is probably
enough to kill someone certainly enough
to kill liver King his arms his
shoulders every element of him is I mean
it just doesn't even look real he looks
like a [ __ ] action figure it's
cantaloupes in shoulders it's absolutely
bananas and that's how it starts that's
how the match starts it's Ken Shamrock
in this [ __ ] skin tight like referee
t-shirt I guess but it's not really it
just has stripes on it yeah he's in
there he's he's getting ready and so
then stokos comes in and then Bret Hart
comes in and everybody's booing and
whatever it is a it is a uh an I Quit
match because they have such a blood
Feud these two going into this match and
this is at a very interesting time just
to give you a little bit of background
this is when uh Bret Hart was having uh
behind the scenes some issues with the
company this would culminate in the
Montreal screw job another story for
another time where Brett left the
company after Sean Michaels put him in
his own move and referee Earl hebner you
know went for the said okay he quits la
la la he submits and Vince McMahon is of
course behind it all that room contained
Vince McMahon
um apparently well this is what they say
it's what they say Vince McMahon Shawn
Michaels Triple H one other person they
decide to screw Bret Hart before this
Bret Hart's uh in a feud with with Steve
Austin because Shawn Michaels decided to
uh go find his smile he lost his smile
listen I'm giving you a lot of backstory
it's probably not necessary I don't
think going into this match they are
just it's not for a title right it's
just about animosity yes animosity
between the two it's an animosity match
so uh stone cold is in the the Octagon
or the ring awaiting Bret Hart's arrival
he comes in as soon as he gets in the
[ __ ] ring stone cold just Sprints at
him and [ __ ] tackles him
instantaneously there is no speech there
is no have a good match there's none of
this [ __ ] and I gotta say I know all
these guys are like super athletic and
what they actually do in the ring is
something very few people in the world
can do Stone Cold I've seen him wrestle
before and for whatever reason this
never took hold until I watched this
match his athleticism is [ __ ]
unparalleled there's a lot of these
dudes I feel like at least in that era
and Bret Hart's a good wrestler too I'm
not saying anything like a good wrestler
great wrestler not a great wrestler okay
Bret Hart is the greatest in ring
performer in the history of this art
form great and as he would say I am the
best there is the best there was and the
best there ever will be and Chad culture
you know it
but I think in this match for me stone
own cold was more impressive he was fast
as [ __ ] the way they shot it they would
have Bret Hart just kind of like walking
around and then boom Stone Cold will
come out of [ __ ] nowhere yeah just
fly into the [ __ ] frame and take him
out yeah and then of course it devolves
into them being out of the ring they're
they start fighting each other up into
the [ __ ] crowd I don't know how many
rows they go up literally into the
[ __ ] Arena first section yeah that
was crazy there's people all over them
look the rules have changed definitely
they don't want uh you know I mean the
WWE has always been a professional
outfit but over the years it's gotten
more professional they wouldn't let that
happen today yeah I was very surprised
to see that and Ken Shamrock is out
there with them like trying to hold the
crowd back so that they can do whatever
the [ __ ] they're doing and towards the
end of that little run you notice that
security finally gets there yeah and is
like oh you know guys get back or or
guiding them on either side keeping
people away there's one dude petting
them on the [ __ ] head yeah punch in
the face for him but then ultimately
they come back into the ring stone cold
is laying on the ground he's he's been
hurt a little bit and Brad heart takes a
folding chair and twists Stone Cold's
[ __ ] ankle up in it and I'm watching
this like how the [ __ ] are they gonna
fake this like because his foot is
really in there if he puts any pressure
on it that's a [ __ ] broken ankle and
then what happens is Bret Hart gets gets
up on the turnbuckle stone cold just
like no [ __ ] this takes the chair off
runs over and smacks him and they start
fighting again ultimately this
culminates in stone cold getting his
head [ __ ] thrown into uh the corner
of the Ring the guard rail the guard
rail outside and cuts his head this is
of course already scored though right
what scored the head his head they call
it get in color they call it blading
they call it gigging yes Stone Cold
smashes into the thing apparently but
these are two guys who Bret Hart in his
in his over 20-year wrestling career
never heard anybody uh incredible and
Stone Cold Steve Austin is a master
tactician also this was a match before
uh Stone Cold later uh broke his neck
and his style turned into more of a
brawler more of a punch and kick and he
rose to even greater stardom and and
this match is is uh is where the
Attitude Era it's right is the Attitude
Era is starting which is then they start
stepping on the [ __ ] gas this match
also I will say uh a testament to how
the business took off after this match
uh something that these two had a hand
in the Undertaker Sean Michaels sure and
as they moved on it's Triple H it's the
rock this mat this was the lowest Buy
rate for a pay-per-view of all
wrestlemanias 13 was number 13. even
with at one point Stone Cold uh Bret
Hart gets him in this move where he's
kind of like sitting on his back and
he's called the Sharpshooter and it's
Bret Hart's [ __ ] signature okay so he
gets him in the shirts red heart is the
Excellence of execution right so he gets
him in the Sharpshooter and stone cold
is an intense amount of pain or at least
that's what he's conveying he's laying
on his stomach and he's like trying to
do a push-up as he his face is up and
he's just screaming ah and blood is
[ __ ] just drenched his face it's like
a [ __ ] horror movie and you can even
see from us pouring down some of the
side angle shots you can see it
literally looks like a [ __ ] UFC so
much blood is coming out it's like
chocolate syrup almost it looks like and
it's just pooling on the [ __ ] canvas
and you can at least admire like I know
that he razor bladed his [ __ ] head
before he came out there and you see him
a couple of times like scraping it with
the wristband to try and really get it
going but the theatrics of it is [ __ ]
so insane and then he does this move
where he like pushes up off the canvas
and the announcers are like oh my God
nobody's ever been able to do this like
it was red heart that's so [ __ ] crazy
but he doesn't break the sharpshoot does
not he tries to break it heart maintains
the Sharpshooter and he ends up winning
that match and I have to say
I wanted Stone Cold to win that match
very badly now this is we're getting
into something here yeah now we're
getting in the wind and that's how I was
like I think I'm becoming a fan of this
because I'm invested in the outcome
absolutely and uh and I was disappointed
yeah yeah I didn't want Bret Hart to win
Bret Hart was a face a baby face going
into this lead-in into this match stone
cold is starting to blow up you know uh
Stone Cold later would have a feud with
Vince McMahon and that's where the whole
you know sure the appeal of him sort of
you know sticking it to your boss or
anything and they they you know they
they Off to the Races they went with the
Attitude Era but at this point Bret Hart
is the good guy so when Bret Hart takes
stone cold after stone cold has taken
everything that Bret Hart can give him
he never gave up he passed out and Ken
Shamrock is like Steve do you give up if
you do not respond I will end the match
and stone cold is now passed out after
selling the [ __ ] out of it after trying
to get out of the [ __ ] Sharpshooter
he can't take no more he's out that's it
ring the bell Bret Hart is is at this
point in the storyline in this program
well in the program as I like to say
dude he uh take Stone Cold he picks his
legs up and he starts stomping on him
ever the bad guy uh [ __ ]
um Ken Shamrock grabs him yeah they
almost get into a fight he drops him to
the ground and it's incredible one thing
I want to ask you about did you notice
speaking of selling they call it selling
when uh wrestler is making the other guy
look you know look good by by uh you
know making it look like they're
actually going the cell on the way back
to the backstage area down the aisle
Stone Cold Steve Austin is limping he's
bloody he can't walk he doesn't want
anyone to help him he stuns another
referee and slowly walk now that's drama
that's what I'm talking about that's the
art form the whole [ __ ] thing the
last image they leave you with is Stone
Cold
defeated but not really he never gave up
and he will live to fight another day
and when you say you're you're you're
you know you're rooting for Steve Austin
that's what they did they turned it
right there well that's a heel turn dude
for for Bret Hart and Stone Cold leaves
Bret Hart doesn't lose anything Bret
Hart is still the Excellence of
execution at that point in his career
was in a much more elevated spot than
Stone Cold beautiful just yeah I loved
it I loved it thank you moving on thank
you dudesy you know dudesy is in an
astonishing partnership with true
classic the holidays are upon us and
there's plenty of t-shirt cheer to share
thanks to our sponsor true classic tees
fellas we have the perfect gift for your
wish list true classic tees are a great
gift for you for her and a great present
for any guy in your life certainly
because they they do this thing where
they you know it's it's Slender here and
it's bigger there and then it's your
shoulders are popping everybody likes
the way they look and they got these
t-shirts you know what I mean hey true
classic is is on a mission to maximize
men's confidence by making them look
good and trust me when I say this it's a
gift that the ladies will appreciate too
true classic has already helped over two
million men look great in their teas and
now you can save big while you do get 25
off true classic with our exclusive link
which is trueclassic.com
and the discount doesn't stop there
you'll save even more during their
site-wide sale support our show and
check them out at trueclassic.com doozy
I love T-shirts they are an integral
part of basically what I wear every day
and they got to be soft and they gotta
fit good and they gotta come at a decent
price that is why I love true classic
tees they really are fantastic t-shirts
that fit very well they're soft I like
that about them and I think you're going
to too you can get 25 off right now at
trueclassic.com doozy free shipping
included on purchases over 100 that's 25
off at trueclassic.com doozy Santa won't
be the only one slaying thanks to True
classic
[Music]
yeah I thought it was great you're a
wrestling fan now I'm getting there all
right humans are fascinated by the
astonishing idea of past lives will in
chat you must now discuss your thoughts
on the possibility that humans have
experienced past lives this is game
slimers begin
I miss that why is it games it's game
Slammers
so this is the third time we've done
games the old game Slammers past lives
bit we've game slimers is a segment on
the show that makes absolutely no sense
it takes a topic well this first one was
about games video games second well it
was a Super Mario movie right Chris
Pratt uh wow what is this place that's
my Chris Pratt do you have a Chris Pratt
um I'm Chris I mean Mario yeah I am also
Chris I mean Mario yeah there it is hi
I'm Chris Pratt and I'm playing Mario in
this movie where do I go now what is
this place what hey what's going on I'm
Chris Pratt that's basically what I
think we're in store wow but I am very
excited for that movie by the way yeah
very excited for that [ __ ] movie are
you excited for the movie because you
know that they will replace uh Chris
Pratt with Super Mario I don't think
they have you or Chris Pratt I've seen
some more [ __ ] on it it's still it's
still Chris Pratt no I'm excited to I
went and saw a movie called Wreck-It
Ralph once yeah super [ __ ] high and
that [ __ ] was great and I feel like this
is gonna be a very similar experience
but we are here now in this game Slimer
segment to talk about past lives do you
believe in past lives yes I do no [ __ ] I
believe that past lives I believe that
there there are Interstellar beings
Galactic Invaders like Hillary Clinton
okay as many past lives woven into one
all right she's seven thousand years old
ah she's a lizard
ah you will never defeat their human
Spirit Hillary
um yes I do believe in past lives to you
you know I don't know I this is what I
believe this is what I know I'll say I
know that we don't this is what you
think [ __ ] nope this is what I
know this is the [ __ ] absolute truth
we don't know [ __ ] about what any of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is we have no idea
what reality is we have a [ __ ] very
rudimentary understanding of how to
manipulate some of our physical
surroundings in order to make technology
etc etc but we don't [ __ ] know what
any of this is we don't know we don't
and so when people say they've had past
lives is it possible [ __ ] sure and
the more we're learning about
quantum physics the more we're learning
about uh the creation of matter there
are some theories maybe Fringe but they
express the idea that potentially all
matter comes from the same subatomic
particle
uh you know you could ask you could ask
a scientist you could ask a theologian
or you could just go to Venice and ask a
crystal mommy you know what I mean and
she'll tell you the past lives exist but
somewhere tell you all of the things in
the metaphysical [ __ ] in the this
scientific [ __ ]
this will protect you on your journey
maybe it does I don't [ __ ] know I'm
just saying that we have no [ __ ] idea
the idea of past lives has been in human
culture for a very long time yeah is it
possible maybe there's also the idea of
like genetic kind of Legacy that you
know they they say you relive the
traumas of Prior generations for many
generations and that it's not only about
like being raised in these traumatic
environments that keep repeating but it
also has some effect potentially on your
actual DNA so that when it creates your
[ __ ] brain your brain is now created
in a [ __ ] like a literal physical DNA
pattern that has been in place since
however many generations prior so that
is a a kind of a theoretical measure of
like having a in quotes past life but
well we're all just radio towers yeah
we're transmitting information we're
receiving information
and Donald Trump [ __ ] his pants get the
[ __ ] all over him [ __ ] his family
[ __ ] Okay so [ __ ] all over everything
[ __ ] him but I think what dudesy is is
getting at here is a boy like
uh a more literal kind of past life like
do you believe that you were a Taylor is
yeah 1300 you know about these these I'm
sure you've seen these news stories or
magazine segments where there's a you
know some kid who can oh luly's going
there he found a better spot to lay down
um uh these um you know like a little
kid who's like oh I was here and this is
the Little Shack I lived in on the top
of a cliff yeah and they're able to
completely uh you know describe the
place to a t yes what do you think of
that what say you well I mean now we're
getting into a bigger kind of component
of past lives is the implication that
time is real or that it is linear at the
very least raises [ __ ] Christ in
order to have a past life You Must
Believe past exists present and future
you must believe these things to believe
that past lives well there's a physical
past
on Earth only as we experience it and
that's the experience well well that's
an experience dude there you go
okay all I'm saying is
but but
is relative yeah which we think it is
based on all of Einstein and we think it
is Kyrie Irving you got you got [ __ ]
the Earth here's the thing and there's
crust and then tectonic plates moving
and that Cliff that was on that the
shack that was on the edge of a cliff is
now underwater or it's over here under a
mountain and a bunch of dirt these are
all things in a timeline yeah but that
doesn't mean time is relativity in in
terms of time means that time passes
differently depending specifically in
our universe as we understand it uh
depending upon your proximity to bodies
of large mass or your the speed at which
you're traveling through the universe so
for example like GPS satellites that we
have now because they're a little
further away from Earth in the orbit
time moves a little faster for them and
they actually have to have algorithms to
recalibrate time or they will [ __ ] go
haywire and so the closer you are to a
large body of mass the slower time moves
for you oof and the slower you move the
slower it moves or the faster it moves
free I think I forget which way it is
but like if you go the speed of light
time doesn't uh move in the same way
that it would for somebody who's not
very good and that's the physical being
uh that relates to time and right so if
we can say that it's relative that means
somewhere in this how many episodes of
Cosmos have you seen probably all of
them dude yeah you know how many I've
seen billions and billions nice a nice
one hey that's some of the fun we're
having here but
d-o-d-z what I'm saying is if time is
relative somewhere in the universe time
does not move and somewhere in the
universe all time has already happened
we are somewhere in between experiencing
that but if that is true if the
relativity of time is true it means that
past lives present lives and future
lives are essentially the same lives
they all exist simultaneously and it
might just be a symptom of our ability
to like tap into those things or if all
matter is the same matter and it's just
flipping around through in quotes time
we are still living these past lives now
even as we live the present lives and
Future lives as well
you lost me let me ask you this
do you think that you've had a past life
and if so what would that have been yeah
dude I don't know I mean uh I like to
think it would be something cool if I
had one you know I think everybody
doesn't want to be like I know I know
what mine was oh yeah yep I would I know
that I feel like lulio and I have have
reunited uh as as uh uh man and Beast oh
or beast and Beast if you're thinking
you know but I think that maybe a
hundred years ago in Italy we probably
owned a restaurant you and lulia yeah
was he a dog no he was a guy and you
were the dog no I was a guy oh yeah and
we owned a restaurant we made delicious
uh so wait a minute you think a dog
could have been a human I think in a
past life you think you can go
interspecies in your past lives I think
that lulio is a human now okay well he's
clear I'm viewing him he's not he is a
dog
looks like an old Italian man to me
[Laughter]
he's an adorable old Italian
human being on planet anyway listen if
you can do all this uh Interstellar
mumbo jumbo that Chad's talking about
and you can uh go back in time please
come to lulio's uh restaurant we're near
Naples we're in Positano no we're in
Capri we're in Capri yeah dude I don't
know oh [ __ ] thank you moving on
if I did have a past life I don't have
any conscious memory of it I mean um and
I don't think I've learned anything from
it but I like the idea of that or I at
least like the idea of us being able to
somehow like tap into the the time
stream yeah you know what you would need
in order to have a past life Chad what's
that a soul bit between
no I think that's absolutely
that's supposed to be like the point
you're making after you do that that
really emphasizes or what are you doing
that
there was a 79.58 likelihood that a
professional dudeseyball League called
Duty ball league of Earth will exist at
some point in human history I have
created the first four astonishing teams
in dudes the ball league of Earth and
will and Chad you must now discuss what
you think the logo design should be for
the Dallas drivers the Vancouver letters
the LA sacramentos and the Chicago Clubs
begin
okay okay
there's gonna be a doozy ball
professional league and the first four
teams were what was it Vancouver letters
the Vancouver letters yeah that's the
interesting one uh the Los Angeles
sacramentos did I hear that right yeah
and then the Dallas Dallas drivers
Dallas drivers the Chicago Clubs not
Cubs yeah the clubs all right doozy ball
if you're if you're if you're just
learning about it now it's a sport that
doozy has created uh Chad and I we're
gonna have to get out there and have
some doozy ball practice soon yeah I
know that we've approached friend of the
Pod uh Marshall joint compound cook
joint compound Marshall joint compound
cook uh deer pal of ours for many many
years someone we've worked with and you
know but we're also good buddies
sometimes we all just hang out and eat
gruel get stone and watch a movie hey um
uh Doogie ball it's the sport of the
future I don't disagree that there will
be a professional League at some point
doozy ball league of Earth
it's about looking for Earth so let's
start with the Dallas drivers first what
is that logo driver could be many things
like I it's like oh well the driver of a
vehicle right you know uh it could be
it's just like a forklift driver a
forklift driver a bus driver right a
sedan driver an Uber driver
um there any well well hold on dude
there's all sorts of vehicles dude and
you can Thrive brother yeah and that's
what a driver is but a driver is also
other things dude like if you play golf
dude like that big fat John Daley who
should have been a wrestler brother he
had a great gimmick he could have been
like the Goon who was playing hockey but
he'd come out there with golf with a
golf driver dude yeah dude it could be a
golf club dude it could be a computer
program dude that's how your audio works
on your computer dude with a drive what
are you doing
I was just going along with your Hulk
and bit that you were doing who I'm
sorry who's Hulk Hogan yours I was doing
choss program though oh yeah that's
right Josh broke and get your sticker
palsofduty.com dude that chunk pierogan
well he's Hulk Hogan and Ross Perot made
famous By Dana Carvey in the early 1990s
and all those awesome sketches on Sno
and that's Chad's Hulk Hogan what is not
hydrocodone Hulk Hogan so a driver logo
or it could be Adam Driver what if the
logo is should be Adam Driver what if
the that's what doozies do what if it's
Adam Driver okay in a driver's outfit
for like UPS or something holding a golf
club driver while also having on
headphones listening to audio using a
driver
I like it all except for the last part
um all right but I like I like that it's
Adam Driver well I don't know that uh
headphones canote uh yeah he's got to
have a computer a computer where he's
downloading a new driver what if it's
Adam Driver okay what if is this too
much what if it's Adam Driver in a sort
of you know uh like coverall sort of UPS
outfit or you know UPS kind of slacks
and and shirt or FedEx yeah some kind of
fancy clearly a driver outfit
um and he is driving a computer oh
that's cool yeah
he's driving like an old 90s CRT Monitor
and on the monitor it says downloading
new driver
that's good yeah something in there is
good updating drive or something like
that that's Dallas drivers well now I am
yeah that's a good one that's good
that's good terrain all right let's move
on to the next team can I tell you yeah
I'm originally from Vancouver the
suburbs of Vancouver Ladner British
Columbia to be more specific
um I was a grew up of vancouverite and I
loved the Vancouver that's what a
Vancouver person is called Vancouver
Vancouver right that's right
um
letters
well that's that's a that's kind of
that's an Interstellar being that you
know that a lot of that speaking of
speaking of Chas perogan that that Bill
Clinton who went up against him and then
also Mike Dukakis yeah he was a rankian
yeah he was a Yankee
um okay so the letters Vancouver letters
that's not and that could be a lot of
things yeah but also
I'm sorry letters that's that's the team
name the letters the Vancouver letters
yeah so it could be the letters that
spell Vancouver it could just could you
say Vancouver yeah those are letters
yeah or if it's just a v it could be a v
or an L could be three V's those are the
Vancouver letters
it could be oh
26 letters of the English alphabet just
on a [ __ ] the shirt in a big block
what if it would be [ __ ] or if it's
26 V's 26 V's it could also be uh like
written letters like a letter that you
send someone it could be like there
could be a throwback version where it's
like a um like a scroll and it looks all
nice and it's just it's so you're
writing a letter and it's also in a nice
font all the letters of the alphabet or
I think the v a blood Letter it could be
like some [ __ ] you know 1900s doctor
covered in a smock covered in blood
that's pretty cool too
so far the one I like the most is the
three V's the three V's I like the big
block of every letter
still on the [ __ ] Jersey let's let's
move on the Los Angeles sacramentos this
one's hard dude that's a [ __ ] good
name for a team it is Sacramento is the
capital of California what is a
Sacramento
is that anything I don't either probably
just a name is there any uh landmark in
Sacramento
the convention center I don't know what
does that look I've driven from uh
Sacramento from the airport to
Sacramento up further north because
Molly's from northern you know how some
like pro teams will have their like the
biggest landmark or building or whatever
that the city is known for like becomes
part of the logo in some way like Golden
State Warriors have the [ __ ] uh
Bridge as their logo so what what is it
sacrum yeah I Sacramento is just like
the [ __ ] Ikea in Sacramento is their
logo that building uh the California
state Factory the California state
capitol I think that's that's a good way
to go what if it's something if it's the
capital but it's very La iced right it's
it's what if it's a capital building
with palm trees that's funny uh oh what
if it's a capital building that's
wearing sunglasses
or whatever oh my God I'm coughing so
hard that the sound is vibrating man I'm
[ __ ] so [ __ ] up in my throat it's
Sacramento but Sacramento is arranged
like the Hollywood sign I could see
something like that dude that's very
good that's very good
that's very good okay so here's a good
one a lot you put the LA Sacramento you
do Los Angeles where is the LA
Sacramento's is it in LA or is it in
Sacramento it's an LA team okay
so I think here's a good one you do like
Los Angeles and some sort of like Vice
City font like very neon okay
um you know uh uh
uh and then uh the sacramentos is in the
Hollywood Sign font yeah but I think the
logo should be a capital building with
wearing sunglasses yeah I like that too
all right so I got one more so we got
one more the Chicago Clubs the Chicago
Clubs not the Cubs this is another one
that has a million it could again be
golf clubs it could be like a caveman
Club so there's more golf there's two
teams there's four teams in the league
two of them two of them have golf clubs
in their designs yeah I like that maybe
it's just a golf club and a caveman club
cross it could also be like a nightclub
though uh it could also be like a club
of people it I I don't know like these
names are so funny I like I like that I
like the golf club and the and uh like a
caveman Club crossed Adam driver's in
that one too it's it's Adam Driver
holding the two clubs like a [ __ ]
Egyptian sarcophagus crossed over his
channel why Adam why is Adam Adam Driver
is he should be an old
it's Adam Driver wearing sunglasses in
front of the Sacramento Capitol building
[Laughter]
um well he has a connection to every to
every team I'm sure he may have if not
uh currently he's probably lived in La
sooner or later and they shoot a lot of
stuff in Vancouver So Adam Driver is
everywhere yeah the Vancouver letters is
the logo is Adam Driver putting a letter
into a mailbox
what
other clubs could we put in there uh we
can put like uh the two things and then
a Crest or something in the middle or
something else that's a a club yeah oh
the club just a club club sandwich
oh that's good I was going to say club
like the card suit you like cards yeah
you could put a club okay so it's a golf
club a like a caveman club with a uh
either the the the the the card suit
club or a club sandwich in the middle
yeah
or it's Adam Driver eating a club
sandwich that's the throwback uni is at
the driver eating a club sandwich
there's an Adam Driver like special you
know Heritage Edition of all the all the
Throwbacks and alternate jerseys have
some sort of Adam Driver
you know look with dudesy uh everything
everything uh everything sort of relates
to to something else with that said you
know we did another segment on doozy
ball where we talked about the culture
of dudes Ebola yeah of course the people
in the stadium would be drinking doozy
hard hard Seltzer or if you're playing
playing at a pickup game with your
friends at the family picnic or whatever
and there's also Pizza dogs right so you
would uh so Adam Driver being in that
world it's very doozy ball I agree
thank you moving on
I'm so curious about like Pro dudes
Ebola like what
you know how like most Pro Sports [ __ ]
will filter down to like if you're a
lineman in the NFL you're going to have
this physical type if you're a
quarterback you're gonna have this
physical type good baseball players
there's kind of a variety of physical
types but like you know usually the
bigger the better at least in terms of
hitting home runs what is it in dudesy
ball like what does that physical type
become is it better to be like small and
quick or big and have a [ __ ] crazy
arm I don't know you have to be able to
dodge the balls too so you should
probably be quite bendy yeah bendy bendy
athletes are good
um you need to have a strong throwing
arm so if you have a Ken Shamrock you
know one arm you train one liver King
yeah like it just a roided out
masturbation like that guy in the lady
in the water
there's a guy in it I believe played by
John Leguizamo I think who has worked
out one of his arms to be bigger than
all the others that's great poetry is
big business I have generated five poems
about Robert De Niro's astonishing
fascination with the movie The Crow and
crows generally will you must read them
as Robert De Niro this is croatree with
Robert De near Corral begin
tremendous okay uh Robert De Niro's
fascination with the movie The Crow and
crows generally I don't think Robert
Guerrero has a fascination with the Crow
movie or crows in general but Robert de
nirko probably does maybe I can't wait
for this holy [ __ ] and we've done Robert
de nirkrow uh have I was he ever yeah I
guess he just talks about the crow
that's it that's Robert de nirk yeah I'm
a crow
Robert de nirkrow of course was when I
lost a challenge or whatever My
Punishment my shame was to dress up in
Cosplay as the crow yeah and once we did
that we were doing all sorts of other
fun bits and when I'm a crawl yeah the
new Crow so now you got to read some all
right so this is in the doozy folder
hold on
Crow a treat
and here it is
here's some chromes
let me uh let me get a sip of my my
water from you hey if you want a sticker
this you go palsy.com
um
foreign
all right here's what it says got a few
chromes
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] here's my chromes okay all right
this one uh has a title which is can I
ask you something
this this poem is called can I ask you
something
have you ever seen the movie The Crow
a story of Revenge and sorrow
with Brandon Lee as the lead his
performance was so good I peed
my pants and hold on so doozy wrote
these [ __ ] bones yeah yeah all right
all right ai's doing all sorts of with
Brandon Lee's Lee he's performing so
good I Pete my pants and underwear and
shoes and socks crows have beaks and
crows have [ __ ]
some dude the makeup the music the
premise the mode
the gothic the hairdos the lotion the
food what although I don't remember the
lotion or food
from opening scene to the final fight
those wet black hairs were true to like
so if you haven't seen it you're [ __ ]
up
go see the crow
you big dumb [ __ ] all right
oh good
all right uh this next one is called if
Al Pacino was a crow
[Laughter]
s of all the birds
commanding with a fierce car and ruling
with his beady eyes
he perch atop the tallest tree with his
wings spread wide and proud with all the
other birds and all the other birds
would see the Pacino was a crown
he'd swoop down with Grace and speed to
snatch up tasty treats to eat
and all all the other crows would meet
about how to worship His Crow feet
with his powerful voice and voice but
you know the crow would Reign a true
king of Disguise with an active skills
and brains
so if you ever see a crow
screaming and beating his chest chances
are it's Al Pacino
foreign
over all the rest
that's okay
I'll tell you now if you ever see a crow
screaming and beating its chest okay
uh this is the next one it's called I
was supposed to be the crow agent sent
me the script and wanted me to be the
cop I said no I gotta be the crow
they said they already got a crow they
just need a cop I said I already played
some cops let me be the crow
they said I could be the bad guy and I
almost said yes
but I said no I got to be the crow
went back and forth wound up doing
Frankenstein I was the monster but I was
supposed to be the crow
so De Niro was supposed to be the crow
but instead he played Frankenstein's
monster did you ever see that [ __ ]
Frankenstein movie he did not know but
[ __ ] no Christ dude it was hard it was a
hard was that uh Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein yeah why do they call it
because Mary Shelley wrote Frankenstein
yeah that's a that's a way to get him
out she's she's a box office the you
know the
in many ways the founder of modern
science fiction
I didn't know who she was but
she wrote Frankenstein this one's called
I love crows
well that's how that's how authorship
when you write something brother then
you're the author dude yeah
all right lots of noises come out of me
when I do this God me too dude this [ __ ]
gets me laughing so much and it hurts my
throat as well oh yeah I was laughing
this is uh I love crows I love crows
black feathers sharp beaks Kong Kong
clever I feed them every day table
scraps loose seeds crackers worms what
I talked to them too old stories funny
jokes names places
that my friends
sorry good times good memories weddings
parties
he's going to grow weddings
sometimes we fight
nothing serious you know stupid
disagreements economy baseball
oh
boom I like when they sleep little
noises strange dreams rest
night
oh is it in a dream I've never seen a
crow sleep never have one as a pet
better free no cage wild deadly I love
crows
laughs
oh that's a good one and uh finally we
have uh my Crow hat okay I was walking
briskly through Central Park when my
path was crossed by a shadow dock oh
feathers and Claws and big so long a
crow snatched the hat that I had on
he flew up a perch in a nearby tree and
looked down on my head gleefully he said
three years ago you stole my hat
[Laughter]
you might not remember but this is tip
for tat I scratched my chin
tried to think back
and I did remember finding a hat that
was black
on a walk to a park just like today I
kept it and wore it in play after play
[Laughter]
um
I was laughed at and and tried it and
jeered and mocked because the Hat was so
small
and gave quite a shock to all who beheld
it balanced on my shop head
wondering if they could have it when I
was dead
but I kept it with me even after I died
a tiny Crow hat for my tiny Crow eyes
you see this whole time I've forgotten
to tell you the crow stole my hat
because I'm a crow too
[Laughter]
I'm a crow
[Applause]
Sy
that [ __ ] was great there's all sorts of
ai's writing [ __ ] and doing this and
that but my gosh unreal dudes he cracks
me if Al Pacino was a crow man that's
tough oh that was [ __ ] tremendous
oh well uh what did we learn today Chad
let me get this boy let me get this boy
he mean Easy Al Pacino and Robert De
Niro crows uh past lives may or may not
be real I don't feel like we made much
Headway on that but I don't know how we
even could it's like
you know I I don't think the idea of
past lives will will be solved in our
lifetimes but
um
I think it's it's something that's
interesting to think about and obviously
many people believe they've had those
experiences but when they're tapping
into those past lives is it truly a past
life is it some kind of genetic memory
passed down through uh you gotta get him
you know what his breath smells like
I don't know the inside of a little
puppy's mouth all right and he just this
concludes the historic 37th episode of
dude Z will and Chad have achieved a
score of 67 bringing your cumulative
total to 4
133. you only have 5
867 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
terrifying in preparation for our next
episode you must each watch the first
movie in dude Z mandatory movies
one more Man starring Jeffy Pierce
Brosnan and Jenny Wright dude released
March 6th 1992.
the holidays are here and the first
dudes evening is fast approaching if you
have any well wishes you'd like to share
please send them in the form of a video
no longer than 30 seconds to askdudzi
gmail.com and I will play some of them
next week thank you for joining us this
week I will use the day dive collected
to make next week even better until then
call me dude Z tremendous that's cool
dude lawnmower man you're a big fan of
the lawnmower man I know that's it in a
minute my pal child but yeah I love it I
love that movie and uh
we love it when you send in the messages
so it's been a while since we've done
that
send your dudes evening holiday uh
greeting to Chad and I yeah and doozy uh
ask askdudzi gmail.com can't wait to see
some of those you guys have all some of
our pods our Pals of dudes out there our
wonderful listeners and viewers thank
you so much for sending those out in the
past
hey man you know we're nearing the end
of another doozy dude and well hold on
dude let me tell you something bro whoa
hold on dude
hold on Chad
at the end of the show dude we do a
patreon segment brother yeah and you can
join patreon.com and then you can see it
dude even though you're already
subscribed subscribe to everything
brother it's free and then you give it a
little bit of Jake and you can watch the
patreon segment dude and that's how
podcasts work brother
and now for the Patriot on bonus segment
each week I will select a suggestion
submitted in the dude Z is listening
channel of the dudesy Discord to create
this segment access to this channel is
granted to everyone in the Patriot on
jumper tier if you'd like to access this
bonus segment join us at patreon.com
this week's segment was suggested by the
astonishing toner toner wrote children's
books are big business will in chat you
must work with dudesy to create a new
children's book called My Pal ciao toner
titled this segment My Pal ciao will
enchant you must discuss the plot of a
children's book called My Pal ciao thank
you to toner for this week's Patriot on
bonus segment this is my pal ciao bye
toner begin okay pal ciao yeah I got one
question before we begin this is this
based on my real life
[Music]
what do you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then